hi guys welcome back
uh thanks for watching us again uh we
have a very
interesting episode today that i i i'm
leading for some goddamn reason yeah i
don't know why you guys trusted me with
this
i should not be trusted it was your idea
well it was mine i
felt like you you said that you would be
able to make us cry
and i trusted that yeah now that's just
sitting the bar too high
you know not for me girl tiff cries like
at the drop of a dime
that's same well nikki will cry because
well yeah you do crazy i drank a little
already and i had some chocolates
my hormones are like yeah very prime i'm
pretty stoked
it takes a lot to make me cry even if i
see other people cry it doesn't like
i don't have that yawn reflex like where
your cry will make me cry you may be
odd yeah you just have to hit your
triggers um
yeah you're gonna have to try a little
harder to hit my triggers because i'm
like a [ __ ] stone cold wall but gina
what is your i'm a soft [ __ ] on the
inside but nobody say that in public all
right i don't want them in yeah
all right nikki however if i even
described a picture of
a cat she will start crying yeah oh my
god are you talking about talking about
the 10 minutes like the pink paws on the
other side
and then well then if you talk about
something bad happening to it
oh that's it's really where it gets
no they don't let's not go there no they
don't so
today's episode i feel very passionate
about your mental health and
and figuring out um what you need in
life
because recently i started going to
therapy
and it's been really nice but before i
get into that let's introduce
who's here right now we have jessica
tiff nicki
you guys are such followers to be a
musical
my name is gino i was just like one day
my name is gina gina so recently
i have been going to therapy because i
really during this quarantine like i
lost my mind
uh like a few months ago yeah that
happened to a lot of people yeah the
silence and the stillness
that's hard for a lot of people i was
like more don't worry
nikki not everyone really my cat was
like now i'm like no
no like i was doing well during
quarantine and then some crazy [ __ ]
happened and i kind of lost my mind and
then that's when i realized
i need to go to therapy and get this
worked out and then luckily
i found a great therapist through nikki
and i've been going to her
and um i feel like everyone should kind
of just do like a mental check-in you
know like you guys at home do a mental
check-in on yourself
see if you're doing okay and i've been
learning so much about myself i've been
going to therapy once a week
yeah it's great do you feel like you
ever did you have much experience with
therapy throughout your life or is this
kind of your first time really digging
in
i kind of dabbled a little bit but you
never did you kind of like start and
stop and you're like i don't need it
kind of
yeah i a lot of people do that yeah so i
kind of dabbled a little bit i'm like
i'm good because one thing about me is
that i was very i've always been very
self-aware
like i know i'm [ __ ] up and this is
why like i can lay it all out
but i never took a initiative to
kind of try to work with it or fix it
there's no fixing it
that's exactly how i was like you're
self-aware you
analyze it and then you kind of develop
your own coping mechanism right
around it right so i decided this time
around like it got
really bad yeah i talked to you guys
about it but it got so bad to the point
i'm like okay let's let's bring
professionals into this and let's take
it seriously
um and kudos to you for actually taking
that step because
yeah yeah just continue to
engage in unhealthy behaviors or even
let it get to the point to where they
there is no return
basically yeah well what's really sad is
not having access i remember
when i got to a really bad point i
didn't know how to access
like it is hard it's hard yeah there are
some organizations like um
well maybe we'll just put a link in the
description but i found some good ones
that
kind of like offer based on your income
level like
if you can't access actual good help
that they
provide services right it's great and in
this episode i really wanted to do an
exercise with you guys that you guys can
do at home also because i feel like it
really helped me
and i feel so passionate about it and i
want to deal with the girls because i'm
curious
but also i'm hoping it might
wake something up inside you to help you
understand yourself more
and i did this on my stream also and
then a ton of people were just crying on
my stream
so i'm like okay this is kind of cool um
great so you want us to be crying in the
club
yeah tissues are here already i do cry
in a club right
handle sensory overload yeah i learned
recently my first sensory overall
yeah i was just in a corner sobbing on
jessica's birthday we were in a club and
i was like i don't know why
we're in a gay club and he's like
[Laughter]
yeah it's like something in my brain
yeah like too much stimulation makes me
just
freak out cry yeah so i wanted to do
that because i feel like it's been so
helpful for me
and i feel like i don't want to see my
girlfriend's cry there's nothing about
it
sadistic yes i'm into you know
um but i hope you guys at home have been
taking good care of your mental health
because it's so important
and for the longest time i didn't do it
because i couldn't afford it yeah and
also for a long time like
uh i'm good i'm fine you know it's like
you're kind of justifying like well i
can't afford it and
well good thing i'm good because i don't
even need to afford it
yeah big but then i realized that 99.999
percent of time i'm good
but that one little smidgen something
happens and i'm losing my [ __ ] yep
um and the back story to this is back in
october or so
i was driving and i have a dash camera
and everything i was driving
um and a motorcycle accident happened
right in front of me
yeah like this guy's on a motorcycle
slammed into the side
you have it on your dashboard camera
exactly and uh he flew off
did a few flips and just slammed into
the ground
and then um like i ran over and tried to
help but then
i have a very deep rooted
uh trauma with motorcycles because i
lost a very close family member of mine
to a motorcycle accident when i was 14
to the point where like if i'm driving
and i see an accident and there's like a
motorcycle i freak out um and this is
the first time that a trauma has
been ripped open in front of me again
and it was
terrifying like i ran over and i tried
to help and i saw him like crumpled on
the ground
like a pool of blood coming out of him
and at first that's fine because you
guys know like i love blood gore i'm
okay with it you know
like i don't mind seeing blood it's okay
but what happened was i looked over and
i saw like a mangled motorcycle
and i completely shut down and i went to
like this weird
i couldn't move luckily like you know
there was people around helping
it was really weird because there was a
fan standing there he's like hey aren't
you gina darling and i'm just like
right in the middle of this psychotic
break the worst time yeah so i'm having
like a psychotic break
and um ever since then ever
ever since then like whenever i drive on
the freeway and a motorcycle zooms past
because we have lane splitting in
california
when a motorcycle zoomed in i'm not used
to that yeah yeah i start
shaking you know and so that happened
you know i was driving like a week
afterwards a motorcycle zoomed past me
and i started shaking really badly and i
couldn't understand like why is this
happening to me like
and i felt weak and i felt stupid i'm
like this is stupid like why
why am i reacting this way and that's
when i realized i really need to get
some therapy i need to work some stuff
out
um and that was like other stuff from my
past and everything so
i reached out to you guys and i found a
therapist through nikki and she's been
great
and she had me do this exercise that
really shook me to my core
and i want to do that with you guys and
i want you guys to do that at home
with or do this exercise at home with us
now i'm scared yeah
like i don't really want to be shook to
my core but i guess i guess we're going
to rip my band-aids off
i might be over selling it but for me it
was very effective
we got some notebooks here because gina
said we have to write some stuff down to
write things down
right i haven't written things down in
ages these are really cute
cute notebooks so i went to therapy
knowing like hey like i have all these
things about me
that i need to work on i had all these
you know i'm [ __ ] up because of this
i'm very aware the therapist is also
like yeah you're very aware of
why you are the way you are but i i
needed to figure out
exactly i needed to zone in
or zero in and narrow down exactly what
it is
that i need to work on about myself yeah
um and she's like okay i have an
exercise for this so let's do this and
see how you feel
right so everyone at home if you guys
can grab a notepad something you can
write with even on your phone or
whatever i'm gonna
say a few things i need you to write it
down and i need you to keep track of it
because at the end of the x
at the end of the exercise you have to
use all that information for something i
use my phone
right so you're like i haven't written
anything in ages you know what let me
use my phone no yeah i am because i
my hand cramps up i'm really like my
hand muscles
that much no anytime i write anything
she goes like
literally yeah you can't even write a
whole word
i [ __ ] grandma with the rheumatoid
arth i'm the one with the rheumatoid
arthritis well girl my joints have been
hurting okay you really want to get into
it
you need some colors my toys hurt joint
issues i do i have joint issues you know
about this [ __ ] i got something i should
just get it tonight
in your phone my joint is [ __ ] up
they don't love me with my joint issues
every time i bend down something cracks
it's disgusting i literally i've been in
pain okay leave me alone my knee has
been
very talkative when i go up my stairs
drop it on the radio the other day and i
tried to but then my knees shattered
[ __ ] so you popped you locked you never
dropped yeah you dropped but he never
got back
so how i did this was i wrote down the
keywords
um instead of writing down the whole
entire sentence so the exercises i want
to say some phrases to you
and each phrase i want you to write from
a scale of one to ten
which one's the most on a scale of one
to ten how much it hurts so one being
the lowest
pain like oh it doesn't really bother me
to 10 being hey
like i don't like that that really
[ __ ] bothers me when i hear that
right
so you'll say a phrase and then we kind
of just write a keyword to remember what
phrase that was
and then we'll write our own like number
of one to ten mm-hmm okay and one to ten
and like you know just like imagine
someone that you really care about
saying
this to you yeah not you not not me
definitely not me no not me
but think of like a like maybe right
yeah excuse me
she's
she gets offended you said never mind i
took it the other way
um so this helped me narrow down
what hurts you the most and the most
important thing that you need to work on
okay
my joints drink more milk
i'll take more vitamin d also i'm just
gonna warn you guys i'm like a drink and
a half in
i think a couple of us drink a little
bit so it might get kind of weird i
didn't drink i'm fairly sober
but you want me to know something you
can like make fun of you more because
like she cried she's dying
[Laughter]
all right so on a scale of one to ten i
want you guys to rate
how much this hurts you one being the
lowest ten being the highest
and again imagine someone very important
saying this to you like you maybe your
parents
your best friend your significant other
okay okay i'm not a little [ __ ]
got it absolutely i've never seen you
cry ever kind of are a little [ __ ]
though
um all right the first is you are stupid
is it a joke no like you're stupid but
you're so dumb
can i go below a one cause i don't give
a [ __ ] if someone thinks i'm stupid
you're stupid you're so stupid
so what i did was i wrote the word
stupid and then stupid and then oh the
number
i wrote that too yeah just easier that
way
you're on the right wavelength yeah you
are nuts you're so smart
look at you good worker good job imagine
your husband
yeah yeah that's what i'm like if he
said that i'd think he was [ __ ]
joking
what about your mom or your dad says it
sounds like a very
most important person like if isaac's
telling me i'm stupid i should
what if he was like mom you're stupid
like you're not smart at all
oh that would hurt yeah how much to what
level more than what i wrote okay well
write the real answer yeah also just use
isaac because i have to really hear
their tone
yeah no imagine like mean is like you're
still you're gonna stay at meaner you're
so [ __ ] stupid you're the dumbest
person i've ever met
i'm your son and i'm telling you you're
stupid okay
okay i'm too narcissistic for that one
because i know i'm not stupid but you're
[ __ ] ugly
that one hurts ugly
the next one is you are so incompetent
that's the same [ __ ] no you can't do
anything right or maybe it's a different
vocabulary yeah you can't do it mom you
can't do anything right
you're a terrible mother mother you
can't do anything right
yeah why are you laughing is this your
covering your pain just smelling
comfortable
oh my god you even are using your phone
and you have
spell check on your phone that's why i'm
laughing
it's like no idea the red line has no
idea
oh god that killed me this shows up a
question
oh [ __ ] it's like incorporate
oh yeah the number you're incompetent
the next one is you're not important
out of everyone in my life you're just
not important are we discussing these
after
because so i kind of want to do it
organically don't even okay you know
like no you know jokes or anything like
the first reaction
right okay i'm still laughing i didn't
call you can't spell important either
just kidding you're not important at all
the next one is
you will never be number one in
someone's life ever
next is you are such an inconvenience
i hate having to spend time with you
you're so inconvenient
next one is you are not lovable no one
will ever love you
you're an unlovable person you don't
deserve love at all
next one is you don't matter i can do
with her without you you don't matter at
all
imagine if steve said that to you isaac
said that to you
your bmw said that to you i don't know
she clearly doesn't think anymore uh
you're your dog your dad
maddy maddie
your dad the next one is you will never
be understood
like no one will ever completely
understand you i will never understand
you enough to care
you are just so [ __ ] up no one will
ever understand you
the next but they will when i'm gone oh
my gosh
right listen i got so many journals
they're gonna dice the [ __ ] out of it i
know everything about this [ __ ] now she
even has diagrams
okay
the next one is
you'll always be alone no one will ever
want to stick by you you're going to be
alone for the rest of your life
no one's ever going to carry enough to
stick by you you're going to be alone
you're going to die alone
well you're born alone you're going to
die alone
the next one is you should have never
been born
i agree
like your whole existence is why are you
here you should have never been born
you provide nothing it would be easier
it's weird how some of these hurt and
some of them don't
yeah right right i also feel like
well we're not done yet yeah so how many
are there we'll just uh one more
okay there's 11 that's an odd number and
i don't like that i know that's why i
thought we were done
the last one is you will never be safe
hmm you'll never be safe you'll never
have a home you'll never have a safe
place ever
depends on how you interpret safe i
guess
i think i have this gene in me that like
if i say it
i'm hurt by it but if other people say
it i'm like nah i'll prove you wrong
if that's what it is if you have to hear
it that way then it's almost two because
like i know that you
love me and care about me so you're
saying it i'm like yeah
i need a stranger to say it yeah you
know imagine for yourself like what if
you truly believe that and you said it
to yourself
you know you'll never be safe you'll
never be safe
mm-hmm so that last one got my heart
pounding
so that's the one look at your list
look at your list and take um everything
that's a five and above
and circle it once okay five and above
okay i got a lot of those
[Laughter]
and then two three four five six are
there any
like the top two or top three maybe they
have the same number as the top two or
three
yeah so double circle that make it
really dark
circle it a few times if you need to
now i want you to make a sentence a very
simple sentence and i'll tell you how to
do it
um take away those top few the top view
that you
darken very much and take away those so
set that aside okay just set it aside
right
now take the other ones that you only
circled once and you're you're gonna
make a sentence out of that
for instance mine was um
i am not lovable and i'll never be
understood
so write down your sentence with those
top few i got four
yeah so i am blank blank with the
one circle of the two one circle okay
and therefore
hold on i've got a lot of them
okay now you take the ones that you
darkened a couple times the two top ones
yeah
and therefore i feel that i am blank and
blank and blank and blank
i have a [ __ ] paragraph over here so
the first half of your sentence is
everything that you circled once
the second half is everything that you
circled multiple times
okay so before we delve into the answers
to these questions i just want to say
new year same couch well actually these
are new couches but at home
say actually just gone listen
same you resolutions are here but this
year they might look a little different
let
doordash focus on dinner so you can
focus on resolutions that
matter like getting food sent to you in
your mouth
directly in and around my mouth well i
have the door dash person drop it off at
my door
and then there's this and then they
buried and i'm like go get that
surf meat directly to my mouth hit that
guy hate him
that's amazing doordash connects you to
the restaurants that you love so you
don't have to look up new restaurants
whatever you love think of the
restaurant you love right now
it's on doordash it's undefensed it's
most likely on doordash
right now right to your door get drinks
snacks other household items
you need some more uh hand sanitizer
can get delivered to your door in under
an hour ordering is easy
you just open up the app you choose what
you want
bing bada boom it's at your door they
have over
300 000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada australia and you can support
your neighborhood go to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeyes chipotle
and cheesecake factory for a limited
time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code mood
that's 25 off up to a 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code
mood don't forget that's code mood for
25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
do you have mud butt no no what is mud
butt mud butt it's like when like when
you poop and you have to wipe like six
times swamp ass
that's awesome crest butt so imagine
every time you poop
it's just like a one wipe and your and
your toilet paper is nice and clean
isn't that amazing yeah for those of you
have mud butts out there
well now you can because of hello tishi
um they said new rear who knew you
in 2021 don't just make a commitment to
wash your hands every time you poop
go the extra mile and wash your butt i
appreciate a good
clean butt yeah um
now with the brand new hello tishi 3.0
modern bidet attachment
it's here to level the playing field
it's stylish eco-friendly easy to
install and affordable
it doesn't just cleanse your butt with a
precise stream of fresh water
it cleans itself which is awesome a
bidet that cleans itself
you don't have to worry about it it uses
the smart spray automatic self-cleaning
nozzle to take care of itself
you don't have to clean it yourself it
attaches to your existing toilet
requiring no electricity or additional
plumbing so you don't have to plug it
into any
plugs ever and it cuts toilet paper use
by eighty percent
so the hello tissue bidet pays for
itself in a few months literally just
wash your butt and use a couple squares
to pat dry
plus every hello tissue pad attachment
comes with a 60-day risk free guarantee
and a 12-month warranty that's a good
warranty
fresh clean butt yeah yeah i love that
you don't have to plug it in
yeah yeah it's easier to install i think
i could be fancy without an outlet next
to my toilet
but now i'm living the good life clean
but
for me you're telling me i had to stick
an extension cord for my old bidet
oh good now that's great so go to
hellotishie.com to get 10
off plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners go to
hellotishie.com
big mood for ten percent off that's
hellotishie.com
ten percent off clean your butt butt you
dirty butthole
so my sentence because i ranked them
from one to whatever we all ranked it
from one to whatever
there was two that hurt me so bad that
on a scale of one to ten i put like a
thousand
and the moment she said it to me i just
broke down and i cried because i
realized this was the most painful thing
and i'm so scared of it
so my sentence was i feel that
i am not lovable and i will never be
understood
therefore i will always be alone and i
will never be safe
so those are my fears so
my two biggest fears was i will always
be alone and i will never be safe
stems from i grew up in a very abusive
family
for the first like or until i was 14.
therefore i was never safe and that's
like terrifying for me
you know like and now like i work so
hard to find
so that i can give myself a safe home so
i can buy a house so i can be safe in
there
um and i feel like i will always be
alone that's my other one because
i i was alone growing up like i didn't
have anyone to talk to
i was either uh ignored disregarded or i
was beaten and i was abused
so therefore my my biggest fears were
i will always be alone and i will never
be safe i was so alone to the point
where
i would call wrong numbers just so i can
hear someone respond to me
and even if they were just saying oh
hello i'm sorry you have the wrong
number bye at least they were still
speaking to me
you know so that is where my fear stems
from
because i was so alone and that's now my
two biggest fears
um and then the others were like you
know i'll never be understood because i
think i'm [ __ ] crazy
or you're a little bit weird yeah i am a
little bit weird um
or i am not lovable because
i have all these crazy things going on
inside me that i don't think anyone can
ever really love me
you know because i feel like this is why
would anyone love this
you know because you don't love you um
or you just because they can't
understand they can't understand
these bits i feel like they must be
wrong to understand like what i went
through
and be able to accept what i went
through you know so
that really when she said when my
therapist said
you will never be safe i freaked out and
i cried immediately
i'm so terrified of that um and
therefore like i seek people who make me
feel safe you know who protect me
like you guys protect me because i know
no matter what you guys will always be
by my side
or whoever i date i need like a big
strong man that will protect me so i can
finally
relax um or i will always be
alone which um i kind of work that
opposite um i keep myself alone
so that or because i feel like if i ever
bring anyone else in there won't be a
vacuum when they leave like they won't
exactly
hurt yeah exactly if they leave me then
use two more
yeah so i'd rather hurt in my own terms
so i keep my cell phone i don't bring
people around
because when they're gone it's gonna
hurt me even more so
i want you to read your sentences out
loud and see
like and i want to know if it's if if
it's accurate for you okay nikki what's
your sentence
all right um so i first want to say
that before steve i probably would have
marked a lot higher
on a lot of these but he like is yours
kind of yeah
like things yeah cause like okay one of
the my top ones
is um never being understood and i feel
like
he fully not only fully understands me
but fully accepts me like every single
part that i felt i needed to hide from
people he
not only loves that about me but he
embraces it and
wants to prop it up and i've never had
that in my life before
and so i feel like if i before him
if i would have seen a therapist and
they were like no you should like those
parts i'd be like yeah right you know
like [ __ ] you
like you don't like no one would ever
like these parts like i don't think i
would have believed that
and he really was the catalyst to like
self-acceptance for me
and it's it's crazy because i just never
thought that
um like someone would
get me and accept me so my my first part
is
um i will never be understood that was
the one circle
which i think would have been a lot
higher before um i also think not
lovable would have been on the list it's
not even on the list anymore
um in fact a lot of these like the
important one would have been on a list
but
i feel like i feel so important now and
i feel
loved and yeah it's really he's a
blessing
but um so i will never be understood
and therefore i feel that i am stupid
and will never be safe
and yeah i think that these do still
resonate
because um because of childhood
uh and okay i'm a drinking so i'm
getting very jumbled but
um let me back up i recently
found out that there's a high
probability that
i'm i have high functioning asperger's
so i didn't know that growing up so i
just always thought like
i'm just weird i'm off i always knew it
was off but i didn't know how so i just
try to blend in
um and though my entire life i've just
felt
misunderstood and i was very smart
academically but socially
so stupid like people will be like why
would you do that that's common sense
not to do that like why would you and
like
constantly like it was so conflicted
because it was like i would get straight
a's and like calculus and like ap
classes but i couldn't understand the
social
norms where like i would just constantly
do [ __ ] that was stupid
and so i just felt like i was so [ __ ]
stupid and no matter how much i like
dotted my eyes or crossed my t's i would
get in trouble somehow like my dad would
be like
how the [ __ ] did you not see this like
why would you let this happen and i just
completely oblivious so i because of
that and because i would get yelled at
and punished for that i just felt like i
would never be safe because i'm so
stupid like i can pass a test i can
analyze
finances math numbers but i can't
[ __ ] understand people
so i don't know how to like blend in
i'll never be blend in all the way
because i'll never like be understood by
people
and so i think that's why i got into
comedy because i was just like well if
people aren't going to understand me
anyway i'll just make fun of my own self
like i'll just make fun of all the
things that people
think are odd or stupid like i'll just
i'll point it out
so that they don't yeah exactly and
and it worked for you know a while but
it's just
you know you get to the point sometimes
like before steve when i first
saw the therapist too was like i just
don't think anyone could ever love me
because i'm so dumb sometimes
you know and even though like iq tests
emotion
intelligence-wise i could pass
everything uh i just couldn't
get the common sense things down so it
always felt like
eventually if i stayed in a group of
friends long enough like they'd
think i was really [ __ ] stupid and i
felt left out of a lot of
a lot of things that's why i think the
important thing would have would have
hit harder before but
now i'm just like whatever i'm important
to steve so
yeah so it seems like steve like if if
you completely black out the outside
world
like you're totally safe you're fully
accepted like steve does
he fulfills pretty much all the things
that you're afraid of and that hurt you
yeah all that but then because you're
still dealing with outside world there's
still a lot of like
instances where you can be hurt by those
things that are still
wounds yeah they're still triggers for
sure like even though
there are exercises and new coping
mechanisms where you can be like
no that's not true like that's not true
you're i'm
i'm not stupid that's not true um it's
and actually like figuring out that
asperger's might play a part in it
really helps because
i went back through my whole childhood
and i was like so much makes sense now
like so many of the signs were so clear
and i even asked my mom about
it and she was like oh yeah you totally
have it i just and i was like why didn't
you take me to get diagnosed like i
could have understood myself better she
was like why didn't you put i didn't
want them to put you on medication
so she never took me in for it but like
a lot of my family members are on the
spectrum
so uh yeah and it's just it was so high
functioning that she was like it didn't
seem to
it didn't seem to matter because like
you still were able to
be very you know social and stuff
because i guess in
in females like you develop masking in
order to try to
fit in with your peers um so that for a
long time they didn't think
females had it because they blended so
well whereas males just let it hang out
um but yeah so it's helped a lot do you
still feel like
like because now you have not only your
husband but then you have a group
now that feels a little bit i mean way
more
yeah okay yeah similar to gina where
like i feel like i seek out people that
feel like home
but i'm also just so scared of i have
that abandonment
issue where i just feel like what if i
get so close i keep my circle very small
but like what if
i get so close and i give that person
since the circle is so small
so much power to like hurt me because
they could just leave it any minute and
then
they could expose me like they could
expose how stupid i
am you know to the world or whatever um
yeah so it really helps to have just
friends that are
just like understanding and forgiving
and like very like
open and like you can mess up and
they'll be like hey like just don't do
it again you know or whatever i don't
know
it's crazy because like if if you if
someone were to come and tell me like
you know nikki has like shitty eq she
doesn't know how to read a room she
doesn't know how to
socialize whatever i'd be like are you
out of your [ __ ] mind
she's the one that keeps us together
yeah i know i feel like you have
so much more emotional intelligence than
you realize like maybe there's certain
things like that you don't catch the
wavelength of like oh that was a joke or
like
yeah you know but then but like when it
comes to keeping people together keeping
people happy
like you're really good at like
understanding what to say of course is
yeah a lot of reading a lot of books
guys books help a lot
um but throughout childhood
i didn't understand how annoying i was
so basically humor was how i cope so if
i make you laugh
you're i'm like oh that's funny so i'll
just keep doing the same joke over and
over again
because it i thinking it elicits the
same response
and so when you get [ __ ] annoyed with
me but you don't want to tell me because
that you don't want to hurt my feelings
but instead you just stop inviting me to
things because i'm too annoying
i didn't understand like why someone who
seemed like they liked me just all of a
sudden stopped wanting to
hang out and it did take like a best
friend to
we i mean it ruined the relationship but
she did
tell me all these things and all the
things that people said about me and
like why she was embarrassed to be
around me and why she would go to things
without me
and stuff and and then like in high
school i was just like you know really
kind of a loner but i feel like i made
friends with other loners so
i have my two best friends from high
school and that's it um
but yeah uh so i just really you know
study people and actually what i really
liked about acting and psychology
is just learning about all different
types of people and
what motivates people what people get
ticked by what angers people
and just like doing a really deep
understanding of
human psychology and understanding
myself too
like and what things i can do and change
to like maybe
you know not annoy the [ __ ] out of
people and like read a room better but
yeah it's it was in childhood it was
very hard because i just didn't
i was a latchkey kid too so i was alone
a lot and i didn't know how to
i didn't know what was normal like you
know and so my dad would be like
how could you do how would you not think
about this i'm like i don't know
i have no idea yeah yeah and i'm the
same way as you like i have
i didn't even know this until i was in
therapy but i have abandonment issues
too
because i never had anyone that stayed
with me my whole life no parents or
anything
so i literally just don't let people in
because i don't want to feel abandoned
if i'm gonna hurt i'm gonna hurt on my
own terms exactly it's not because
someone decides to just leave
yeah and that's the reason why i like
you guys you guys are my closest friends
but you guys never really see me
and that's a part of me that's just like
i get close
but like i will be there for you at
three in the morning if you call me
yeah but if we didn't talk forever i
wouldn't assume something was wrong
right
and that's why it's easier for me to
just cut people off too because it's
like all right i'm cutting you off
and like you [ __ ] up you're gone i'm
you're in control but if it was the
other way around
i i can't handle it like i will lose my
[ __ ] you know totally yeah
so i understand like the whole
abandonment thing but
i i'm really proud of you that you
worked that out because you reading that
i was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
yeah that's bizarre to me that you don't
i didn't think i would cry actually
either
because i'm like that's stupid i don't
feel that way anymore
but then when i read it i'm like yeah
yeah it really reflects a lot of
how i felt throughout life right the
whole like um
abandonment thing that i had i feel like
we all kind of have that
yeah yeah there's this like on her like
first session she kind of like uh
did an assessment of like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me and right before
we ended our call she was like hey gina
i just want to let you know
one thing also it's very important i'm
not going anywhere
and i lost my [ __ ] i just cried because
that's the only words that i want to
hear
ever yeah and i was like i was like i
started crying but then i was always
like
first of all how [ __ ] dare you do
this to me right before we hang up
you knew what you were doing now you
need to unravel this thing how dare you
maybe it was appropriate though because
of the previous therapist
yeah that's true the previous therapist
that i tried she kind of disappeared out
of nowhere
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] which is such a
weird thing like oh you have abandonment
issues oh yeah by the way
i'm abandoning you yeah like all right
cool thank you
um tiff how about yours what's your
sentence my turn i'm nervous okay
my sentence so i only circled three
things
so it's pretty short it's i am stupid
and therefore i feel i am unlovable and
unsafe okay how do you feel does that
feel accurate to you
um do you feel like it stems from
somewhere
i don't know about the unlovable part
because that one
even though like i i put a six out of
ten
but like hmm i don't know because and
also the stupid one i
ranked out of five so it was like right
on the border but
that one only hurt thinking isaac would
call me stupid yeah
it depends on the person's right because
then i thought of like casey calling me
stupid
i'm like um not really
i mean we've had fights and he's called
me way worse things
and i'm like okay but but yeah like
thinking isaac called me stupid that
that did hurt a little bit
that would probably hurt any parent
though to like that's almost like just a
part of the parent-child dynamic i think
yeah maybe that doesn't really go very
deep with you as a person but just that
you want to be a good mom
maybe because i thought about isaac
calling me incompetent and i ranked that
at two
like yeah even though i don't care if
i'm a shitty mom [ __ ] you kid
so i'm like um i don't know or like him
telling me i'm not important
that was like a three because i'm like
you're like i don't believe it i don't
believe it
yeah all right sorry guys one more quick
break just to say thank you to our
sponsor and this one is for third love
my favorite bra ever i'm actually
wearing it right now i'll flash you a
little bit you see this
over the shoulder boulder holders
[Laughter]
so third love uses the measurements of
millions of women to design bras with
all-day comfort
and support so you first take a fit
finder quiz
and now third love just launched the
fitting room so it's a new and improved
version of the quiz that focuses on
size breast shape current fit issues and
your personal style to deliver bras and
underwear
that are perfect for you if you don't
love it every customer has 60 days to
return
returns and exchanges are free and easy
third love creates better bras that
focus on what matters
keeping you comfortable and oh my god
they're so comfortable
you know recently i i reordered some
more bras
and i realized that the previous bra
that i had it actually fit me a little
too small
and i could have returned it but i'm too
lazy so i just kept it and it was
comfortable anyway but
this most recent bra that i ordered i
ended up i sized up but they actually
have half sizes so now
i'm a cup a half cup bigger or whatever
like i
sized up and it's a perfect fit it
doesn't actually like dig
into my sides or into my shoulders at
all and
and that's all avoidable with the quiz
that you end up taking you know the
returns are so
damn fast because mine didn't fit me the
first time so you
go online and you click oh hey i need a
different size they already shipped the
new one like the same day
so like i barely even i didn't even mail
the other one yet and the second one
came in
my favorite is seeing all the different
pictures of all the boobies and like
trying to figure out what my boobies
look like i know i had to ask casey i'm
like yeah
baby which which one i just had to look
in the mirror alone
oh sorry anyway back to third love
before we all get depressed
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they're
offering
our listeners 20 off your first order
go to third love dot com slash big mood
now and find your perfect fitting bra
and get 20
off your first purchase that's
thirdlove.com
big mood for 20 off today all right guys
times are tough and worrying about your
student loan payments doesn't make
things any easier trust me i know that's
where
refinancing with earnest could help
earnest offers
low rate student loan refinancing and
you can check your rate
risk free in just two minutes with
earnest you'll get radically flexible
payments and you can pick your loan term
by refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money or combine multiple
loans into a simple monthly payment
if you have questions you can even talk
to a real life human for help
isn't it time you stopped feeling
overwhelmed by student debt
yes it sure as hell is ernest is
offering our listeners a hundred dollar
cash
bonus refinance your student debt at
earnest.com
big mood terms and conditions apply
now ernest is giving our listeners a
hundred dollar bonus
refinance your student loans at
earnest.com
big mood the terms and conditions apply
once again you can get a hundred dollar
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
big mood to refinance your student loan
not available in all states
terms and conditions apply visit
earnest.com big mood for more details
terms and conditions apply
are the student loan refinancing by
earning operations llc and mls number
one two zero four nine one seven
california financing law license number
six zero five four seven eight eight
three or three seconds straight sweet
four one in san francisco california
nine four one seven
a full list of lenses so i don't know
like for me it was difficult to kind of
do this exercise and really feel
connected but the one that
really like it made my heart [ __ ]
sink was the
not safe where do you what do you feel
what do you think you feel not safe
about where does that come from um
yeah intelligent you know just not being
safe protected by the ones that should
have protected you yeah is what it is
you know like that one's rough she said
that children are very resilient like
you can come up to a kid and be like
you're dumb they're like
no you're dumb but to be able to break a
kid like that
means something really bad happens to
them that actually it reminds me um
in my therapy session my therapist asked
me to picture myself
and my past and just it doesn't matter
what age just picture myself
in my past so the age that i thought of
myself i was four
and she was like okay so you see little
tiffany there
four years old um what do you want to do
to her
like what do you want to do with her and
i'm like i just want to hug her and
protect her
yeah did you do those visualization
exercises where you like
as your adult self who you are now you
like walked in and like kind of sat with
yeah the childhood version of her and
then i took her and then she was like
okay
so you're hugging her like what what do
you want to do now
i'm like i just i want to play with her
i want to take her to the playground
and give her a decent childhood yeah
do all the things that she didn't get to
do yeah yeah
so like you were kind of robbed of you
were kind of robbed of your childhood
yeah kind of i think so it feels like
that so
i think a lot of us were for sure
a lot of women yeah a lot of women were
robbed of their childhood and made
to feel unsafe even with like little
things when you're a kid it's just like
at six years old hey don't wear that
dress around that man you know
why it's just a dress i'm just a kid you
know and
it's a lot of i just feel like almost
every woman i've met
their childhood was not safe
their childhood was robbed from them you
know
and i relate with you like the whole
safety thing is terrifying
yeah everyone hurts the most because
when you're a kid like you're supposed
to be protected
you know the people that were there to
protect you they failed to do that
and because of that it still resonates
with you now it still affects you now
yeah and yeah definitely and um
i feel like that that
uh wound is really hard to like heal
with um even in
adulthood it's just you know with
certain
situations and stuff and just it feels
hard to still feel
safe right so
yeah that one was the roughest one the
unlovable one
yeah it didn't really hit me that hard
even though i ranked it kind of high
but i feel like i'm loved i don't feel
unlovable
but yeah that was my sentence i love you
i love you too
i would keep you safe thanks mama
yeah that's crazy i mean i rated the
safe one really low but
i i do know that uh like the other day i
texted you guys and i was like
yeah um i i started panicking like in
the middle of the night because i was
like oh well i'm
i'm alone and i've been isolated because
i'm like you know isolating from
coronavirus and also i don't have a
partner right now so i've just been
alone in my apartment for like two
months at a time like it was like a long
period of time where i didn't
really see anybody at all so one night i
just got freaked out and i was like wait
if i like had some sort of like
spontaneous medical condition or
something or if i
slipped out of my tub and like fell on
about like then i would just literally
be laying there i could be laying there
for three or four days and like i don't
think anyone would
notice because like we don't text every
day or like yeah so we made a mandatory
rule now
yeah she has to text every day that
to me is like my anxiety talking or like
some weird
um what's the word again for the medical
uh
where do you think you have like a
certain thousand no no uh
hypochondria hypochondriac yeah so i do
have that i've i've
grown out of it a bit but i think that
was just a little bit of the
hypochondriac
kind of anxiety coming out like oh what
if i spontaneously have a stroke or
something like
stuff that's probably not likely to
happen but that scared me so but that's
not really like
safety i think in the way that you guys
are talking about it um
the alone part of it is probably more um
important in this but so i circled a lot
of things
[Laughter]
um i i had one two three four
that were over or six actually there
were over five
and uh two of them were nines so i made
the first part of my sentence with the
other four
which was um i'm not important i'll
never be number one to anyone
uh because i'm an inconvenience and i
don't matter
and then so the second part of my
sentence was therefore i feel i'm not
lovable and i'll always be alone
so i don't know
i don't know why
i don't know i have a hard time with it
like really tapping into it because i
like i'm i'm on this precipice in my
life where like i
i'm kind of like sometimes i get really
sad and i will cry i'm like oh man i'm
just i'm probably not the type of person
that's gonna have a husband and i'm
gonna be alone forever
but then i'm also almost a little bit
over the cliff where i'm like
actually you know what i i am a lovable
person and if i exist and someone like
me does exist and and maybe i'll find
them maybe i won't
i'm hoping that i do um but
i don't know it's it does hurt it's it's
weird because it's just like think the
thought of being alone like it
it hits me at night i think that's what
it is like during the day when i'm
functioning and i'm doing stuff like
the the pain of uh the fear
doesn't really hit me until the sun goes
down it's nighttime and then i'm alone
and then i'm like oh damn like i look
out in the night sky and i'm like it's
just dark
and i'm there by myself and it does feel
like heavy like
the loneness does feel very heavy but
then during the day
i function so well and like i'm i'm very
excited for the future distracted
and there's stuff to do yeah so it's it
doesn't
hit me as hard but then also i've just
gotten into this routine where like
i'm used to being alone now so like it
used to it hurt me a lot like in my
young 20s like i would just
i was on drugs at one point like i was
doing a lot of destructive things i
would be in destructive relationships i
would stay with men that were not good
for me just because i couldn't
be alone but now i'm finding like a
comfort in being with myself i feel
safer with just myself because i think
because i've chosen so many
problematic people to be in my life that
it is safer to be alone because i just
haven't chosen the right people to be
around
until now not you guys obviously yeah
there's very manipulative
yeah there's just there's i've i've gone
down the road with the
with a lot of toxic people because
that's just what i like i was raised
with
toxic water you can suss out
vulnerability too yeah like they're like
oh [ __ ] this girl
exactly so like like malignant
narcissists and stuff like that like
they'll
they'll find me and i'm like such a good
trap for them so like now i just feel
safer alone and for some reason i just
put the safe out of one because i'm like
i feel in control of myself i feel
empowered i feel strong
do you think that by myself maybe
because like it's almost like you faced
your biggest fear
probably completely alone and it's like
not that bad so yeah
oh [ __ ] if i could if i could do this
and
yeah how would i ever feel like it does
feel i think it feels more sad and
almost like
uh such a waste of time like if i have
to go through life alone like oh man i
won't get to experience like how you
have that connection with steve where
like you feel
like your souls are so connected like
you you're 100 fulfilled by him
understanding you and
accepting you i'm like man that would
really suck to not get to experience
that and it'll be like i
i i missed out on like one of the most
important parts of life and so it's
almost like i'm
sad that i would miss out on something
versus it what's also supporting me
i think it's like you loving yourself
more is like oh this is sad that no one
else gets to experience how cool i am
like
it's in like a way where you're like man
like i really
cuz when i feel like i did something
cool like i'm like oh i
made a candle or whatever yeah i want to
show somebody like right away i want
someone to be like look what i made and
then be like whoa you made that
oh cool you know yeah it's almost like
you finally found yourself and like all
the lovable parts about you
yeah and to not be able to share that
with someone and go like look look what
i mean yeah
look i think them being like i like that
that's cool
it is a waste i do feel that way so like
on the ones on um
being understood i rate that pretty low
like or being stupid
like i just that to me i
have probably too much confidence that
i'm not stupid and then
like that and i don't know the thought
of people understanding me literally
never crosses my mind
like i don't know why like i never got
like there's probably things about me
where people are like why is she like
that so [ __ ] weird but like
that literally affects me zero so but
yeah just i guess
you know there's just a lot of these tie
in together about being important or
mattering to someone or being
an inconvenience i've i've had a lot of
relationships with men who did make me
feel like i was an inconvenience
so that rated high for me
um well in your childhood relationship
yeah yeah like with my mom like it was
just like i was inconvenient because she
just wanted to
use or whatever but it's almost like i
understand why
and now it's almost like i see people as
um they're all
hurting and they're all kind of broken
and they're all kind of [ __ ] up so
it's like
it's not really my fault anymore you
know that's good
yeah because having the same therapist
as gina um
part of that is even though as an adult
i can understand it
like oh i get why you know my mom
and dad both had to work full-time so
they left me in the care of a full-time
nanny from the time i was six weeks old
throughout my entire childhood
because they had to put money they had
to put food on the table you know as an
adult i can understand that but as a
baby
you're just like my mom left me and i
don't know when she's coming back yeah
and i'm not safe like i'm not safe here
and so whatever coping mechanism you
developed as a baby that you can't even
remember now
stays with you in your body in adulthood
so
um and it for me it definitely reared
its ugly head for a lot of my 20s like
like how i said i just had very
unhealthy behavior unhealthy
relationships but
i don't know where it went like it just
stopped all of a sudden and it was like
a lot of work for yourself
you've been doing a lot of work i want
to say it was this year because
i obviously wasn't still making good
choices even just a couple of years ago
like
yeah i quit my career out of nowhere if
i could move across like i wasn't making
logical decisions that i knew were going
to be good for me i was just like
[ __ ] whatever
yeah i've known you for like a little
over two years
and you're a radically different person
it might be for more than two years
i mean i feel like the first time i've
hung i hung out with you was like
2018 or maybe end of 2017
but yeah fact check that yeah
i'm like i feel like we know each other
more than two right it feels like it but
yeah
yeah i feel like you've you've changed a
lot especially coming out of
your old long-term relationship and the
progression of you being single
and like where it first started some of
the realizations i made while
dating being newly single but like
dating
guys like that kind of put me through
the ringer again it was almost like i
never
like they didn't wake me up when i was
younger but now
it's almost like i have so much life
experience that the you can see patterns
yeah i was like oh so a lot of [ __ ]
clicked
into place for me and i it's almost like
the alone part of it sucks because
i almost feel like i don't think that
anyone's really going to be good enough
now um
so that's such a it's such a wild that's
a great problem
but it's scary because i'm like damn
like i'm not gonna find someone that's
good enough for me
yeah i can't wait till you find that
person oh i'm so excited for that i feel
like
yeah if i exist he has to exist he has
to statistically does he live in los
angeles i don't know
there's 10 million people here i don't
know but there's like seven billion
people in the world what if he's
somewhere else
there's more than one yeah there's
definitely more than one there's more
than one the one
yeah there's the 30.
yeah i know i hope so but i just feel
like everyone has so many problems and
it's almost like do i even want someone
else's problems because i already got i
already got through mine
yeah you definitely want someone that's
done work on themselves and that's why
i'm so happy that
therapy is more accepted in this
generation than it has been in any
previous generation because you can bet
that like
more statistically more people are
seeking therapy
are working on themselves or endless at
like some capacity
so and they never really did before
because our parents and their parents
yeah everyone before them were all
[ __ ] up they were in these shitty
patterns
they think it's silly they had no they
had no self-aware it's like a weird
like they had no self-awareness
my dad is just like no i don't need
therapy it's [ __ ] whatever it's like
dude it's really good i think that
therapy's for crazy people
exactly people still think that therapy
is just for people who are just insane
who have like really [ __ ] up mental
issues but
it's like outdated thinking yeah like
it's good for your if like if you can
get
yearly checkups for your body you should
for your brain and your mind too
yeah so like with this exercise it made
me realize like
yeah there's a lot of other things going
on in my brain but these are my most
feared my like what i really want to
work on the most
yeah what are like some of the exercises
like do you
do are you okay with sharing like yeah
so she told me like
okay so now that we've identified these
things i want you to understand that
um there's a difference between
identifying with or just identifying
so all these things that i'm feeling
like i'm never understood
i will always be alone and i'm never
gonna be safe
right now i'm identifying with it like
oh yeah that's totally me that's me
that's me that's me
but she's like no like that's not you
like you just need to learn how to
identify it
like i see it like oh no that's a fear
that i have but it's not necessarily
true about me like you
you accepted it too much into your
identity where it's like it's not
actually a part of you
exactly thing that you've been adopting
for so long
and i think you can get there because i
think that's what it's happened to me
now where it's like oh i can identify i
have abandonment issues i have all these
things but
they don't even feel attached to me
anymore but like i can see that
so i think you can you will eventually
stop
identifying with it right do you feel
like you've lost any of them yet are you
shedding any of them yet
uh i'm doing a i'm happy i i'm
making a better effort at just
identifying it and not letting it affect
me
so it's like it's it's almost like
i see you you're there but i'm not gonna
let you bother me
sometimes personifying it and like
giving it a whole character name
and stuff like helps to separate it a
little more like
yeah oh there's my stupid sally that
thinks i'm stupid but
she's just she's annoying she'll go away
right that's what i was doing with the
whole ego thing
yeah like tiffo creeping up again
yeah yeah that totally helps right
so i i feel like it's been like um
i'm the more that i understand it the
easier it is for me to be like hey like
sit aside
you know like i know you're not really
you're not really there i'm just
blowing it up in my head you know like
monkey brain it's just like some natural
thing that's
exactly and that's what they say like
when you try meditating and stuff like
that
that is a form of meditation when you
observe
when you like get a thought in your
brain and instead of attaching yourself
to that thought and then like running
with that thought
you're just like oh there's that thought
there it is okay
see ya all right yeah yeah yeah
um and then i think the thing that she
that really resonated with me was
um she's like this is your blueprint
like this is how you think this is your
blueprint
and it's not your fault like this isn't
fair because it's the people
that raised you from like zero to six
it's them they did this to you and so
you don't have to keep following this
blueprint we're gonna break
it down and we're going to rewire
make a whole new blueprint so that you
can build a better building
you know a stronger more fortified
building
so it was like it's for me it was more
like
when i came into therapy i was like i
understand why i am the way i am
this is why this is how i react to it
but i needed to understand like we can
work this out
yeah you know and the rewiring yeah the
tools to do that
yeah because i feel like a lot of people
are people are like
this is how i am that's just it yeah i'm
not gonna do anything about it that's
just how it is you know i've been like
they wonder why the same patterns
keep happening over and over again that
they don't like yeah so
now i'm just like no like we can rewire
this this is you know this is totally
something that we can work on
and that made me feel a lot better about
myself and
like it's been way like it's been really
beneficial like i've been really
happy with it um it has been kind of
scary though
yeah you know like because it's like
what if i'm the one person that you can
rewire one thing that she told me that
really helped was
because at first when i went i was like
maybe it's just chemicals like
because i can't explain like a lot of
the things um also i think getting off
birth control like birth control
hormones play a huge role
in mental health too which i didn't
realize until i got off i was on him for
like
i don't know 13 years straight or
something like me too um
yeah so i didn't i think couldn't
separate who i really was from
when i was on hormones but um one thing
that helped me
with her was because i thought it was
chemical she goes it might be
you know for some cases out there
you may need medication but she sees
that more as a last resort rather than
like let's just put you on some meds
and so she had some referrals to
psychiatrists if it
got to that point right who they they
could refer they could
prescribe drugs drugs but um yeah
going through that all of that rewiring
stuff i
came to the conclusion that yeah if with
enough practice like
i don't think i needed to go the medical
route
not ruling it out for everybody but yeah
at least knowing that in my mind like
that's a last
resort that okay if i am some
exceptional case
that there's there is the medical route
yeah yeah i think one of the things i
learned from her was um
so i remember like my first so i
actually went and
i i started working with her
like one of her employees so she's like
the owner of the whole facility right
yeah so she's like head honcho whatever
but she was like super expensive and so
um
she put me with one of her like uh other
employees
she was a little bit cheaper and still
licensed therapy still licensed
you know yeah but not like the owner
yeah the head honcho
and the the her one of her employee
the first day that we spoke she was like
okay tell me about this and this and
this and this and this i want to know
about everything blah blah blah right
but that didn't like that kind of
didn't work out because suddenly she
disappeared and i was just like what the
[ __ ]
you just unpacked all your luggage and
yeah like bye
exactly it was a waste you want you want
to clean up this mess later yeah i paid
for it and now she's gone
and then so i hit up the head honcho and
i was like hey so this happened
and it kind of makes me feel like i'm
not really
confident in your your facility's work
now and so the owner she was like
all right you know what i'm going to
take you on and i'm going to do it for
her price not my usual price i'm like
okay
so my first session with her and i'm
like hey how come you're not asking me
as many questions
like like as the other one like she she
she asked me questions about everything
about myself
and then she goes you do realize that's
your anxiety
talking right like [ __ ] yeah because
like for me it's just like when i like
someone like even in dating my
[ __ ] manifests in my dating life
everything else i'm fine but in my
dating life it's like why aren't you
asking questions about myself it's like
your most vulnerable
relationship that you're going to have
in your again in your adult life it's
kind of like your parent relationship is
the most vulnerable
right as a child so it's like the equal
right so
family relationship it's like it's gonna
be there because i'm stuck with that
that's my blood
yeah but romantic relationship that
means i'm letting you
in this is my decision so that's where
it manifests and
it it scares the [ __ ] out of me so i was
like why aren't you asking questions
about me like why aren't you getting
trying to get to know me why aren't you
trying to understand what are you doing
during the
session she would just be like all right
so talk basically you know and i'm just
like this is weird your other employee
she asked me everything and she goes you
know she's like i'm already reading you
right now yeah
anxiety sorry yeah so she's like you do
realize this is your anxiety
yeah like you you like me when i like
someone i want to know everything about
you
i'll ask every question ever tell me
everything about yourself and she goes
this is your anxiety she goes i don't
need to ask you questions because
normally in life
it's just going to come naturally yeah
eventually i'm going to learn these
reveals
it reveals itself so you're freaking out
that i'm not asking you questions
because you're so scared like this
woman's never going to understand me
she's never going to understand how to
work even interested yeah and that was
one of my my
sentences like i will never be
understood yeah yeah and i was like when
she said i was like
you [ __ ] you're a genius
[ __ ] you know and she's like um
she's like that's that's what it is like
you're so anxious you you need to be in
full contact you need someone to
understand you so bad but you need to
understand that
not everyone's like that and everything
will come out eventually naturally
and that's like one of the big things
that i learned about what it's like
to date me yeah you know that's so
interesting
i wonder if you attract a lot of
narcissists because of that they love to
talk about themselves
[Music]
no i've never dated a narcissist before
okay yeah
um but i do struggle with people like i
dated a korean guy once
and they're raised to be very quiet
stoic doesn't really talk oh so you're
attracted to people that
won't give you a lot so you need like
you dig yeah you want to be the one that
gets to them
yeah i'm like why aren't you asking me
questions what the [ __ ] wrong with you
so that makes me want to dig more
and then from that i relate to that yeah
so from that she told me she's like
um and i told her about that
and she was like you need to understand
that
cultural differences are not personal
this is how they were raised
like korean men were raised to be like
quiet stoic never talk about anything
so you can't take that personally and i
was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah so it's like
i went into therapy very cocky yeah this
is how i am
i know why and then she broke me down
and i was like [ __ ]
i get that because you and i do a lot of
like self
like reflection like you know you go
we're alone a lot
right exactly um and we're like yeah i
gotta figure it out yeah i get this
but then there's like why is this part
going to park keep happening right this
is just broken and
i'm never going to fix it i totally went
into therapy hockey too
yeah so i was like well i've been in
therapy before i've dabbled
they don't tell me anything more than i
yeah i've already told my story
my mom could tell me this well a lot of
times when people go to therapy like
they're not
going to like a very good one yeah
there's a lot of life coaches out there
and stuff where they're just like
doing the most basic like oh tell me
what happened to you as a child or
something and you're like well i don't
need to really like i need to know
beyond that yeah you know yeah that's
where i'm
kind of at to like with my previous
therapist like
she was she was good but i didn't feel
like
it was good enough to get me to
fix things or like work out things
she had me do this other thing too where
um i forgot the type of therapy that she
did but it was
something about your body so like she
had me close my eyes and visualized
like my problem that i was talking about
in her office that day and it was like
the biggest problem that i had that i
kept continuously talking to her about
and she was like what does it look like
like when you think about this problem
what does it look like to you
and i'm like it's a disgusting gooey
mess like it looks like
the swamp thing it's [ __ ] gross and
smelly and like i just i fully described
how
i visualized this problem and she was
like all right now put that
like now visualize a box and then uh
like a trunk
and you can make the trunk look however
you want so and i described her the
trunk that i had
and she was like all right now i have a
swamp thing go inside the trunk and lock
it up and i'm like
okay that now what like
what do i do with this and so i did i
did it and it did like alleviate
a lot of that like that i was feeling
but
it felt like i just like bottled it up i
didn't feel like i actually worked
through it stuffed it something yeah so
i'm like hm
i don't know like so i kind of stopped
seeing her because i'm like i don't know
i mean maybe i should have given her the
benefit of down and continued i don't
know where she was going with
that but she also had me do things like
talk about like a different issue like
okay when you think about this person um
how does that
make you feel in your body and i'm like
oh my god i feel like a knot in my chest
or whatever it is and then like okay now
observe
that knot in your chest and like she had
me hold these like little eggs
that would like bounce the vibration and
the eggs so it was like something she's
talking about
yeah there's like different yeah like
tapping too and like she talked about
like in
um i forgot what culture now i i'm
really bad at remembering
the history of this method but it was
like some different culture that they
would use this like
thing for them to like like brain right
brains
yeah like to release trauma out of your
body because it not only does it live
within my minds and my emotions but like
it literally lives in my body so when i
describe that not in my chest like
that's where that lives
and so like she was trying to like help
me work through
how to release it and yeah it was just
really
odd so i don't know i didn't really
stick with it that much she was really
expensive too so i'm like i don't know
how much longer this is gonna take
i've been in and out of a lot of therapy
too and i never felt like anything
worked but i don't know if it's just
that
you learn things along the way until you
get to a point where you know how to
to dig it out so i just always felt like
all the therapy i've done is
never worked at all but i also don't
know if that's just like
it eventually added up to a place where
i could help myself
right because it just never it never
felt yeah it never felt like
time i went to an appointment and then i
felt like it then it didn't
like there was no immediate there wasn't
a result yeah it was just like
for some reason like this year i finally
dug out some [ __ ] that i could never dig
out
and but it was that just a combination
of you know like 10 years of being in
and out
yeah of course i don't know working on
yourself yeah like
repetition sometimes i'll read like i'll
read like 10 books on the same subject
and mostly they'll say the same thing
but for some reason on like the eighth
book
it kind of simply clicks that i'm like
i've read that before
and i know that you already knew it yeah
but for some reason it just clicked
differently
yeah yeah yeah it could be that too yeah
that's true
so yeah i actually i'm curious i want
the number to this therapist i want to
see that she's
she has for me yeah what i like about
her she developed the whole system to be
completed in 10 sessions rather than
like on dragging it out
yeah she's actually really against that
and that's why she started her own
business because her mentors like were
all just like no just they keep coming
back forever and she's like but
we're not healing these people then
nothing's getting healed
yeah so it's like a 10 step like today
we're working on this this level this
level on this level
and i i went into it just like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys are gonna give
me some random spew some random [ __ ]
i could have read it in a book
but then the more i went to her the more
like she was telling me things that i
already knew but she also
opened up like deeper doors like that
made me
there's a lot of moments and i'm like
you [ __ ] how dare you
you're so right you're playing chess
with her yeah and she like checkmated
you and you're like how the [ __ ] did i
know
exactly i'm like upset you know like i
understand me the
most how dare you first of all show this
mirror in front of me you know
so it's been it's been very interesting
and she does it so
it's almost like effortlessly yeah she's
like hey this is why you're [ __ ] up
i'm like oh [ __ ]
you know and it's been very insightful
and like i went into this
thinking like understanding like this
might not necessarily
fix me because i feel like there is no
fixing yeah you know you just learn
to understand it better live with it
better and not let it
not let it keep you in the same loop
over and over and over again yeah
getting out of the loop is uh
yeah i mean what what even is fixed like
a human is not a thing
like healthier coping mechanisms not
necessarily
fixing a broken part yeah like hey you
used to cope like this
crying for hours on end and now you cope
like this because you can
identify it separate yourself from it
and then do this activity instead right
yeah
yeah so it's it's helped me on a daily
life like
oh i'm doing this because of this she
said that you know so
now it's just like okay so i'm not
really like that you know it's just that
this is affecting me and it helped me
kind of it's called it's more like a
course i adjust my course better you
know yeah so it's been helping me a lot
yeah yeah because even when you
originally do this exercise i was like
i don't actually feel like not this at
all but like
picturing steve called me stupid was the
only one that i was like okay yeah
if he really truly meant that from his
chest that would hurt
right but like if anyone called me
stupid
normally i'd just be like you don't know
me
you know but like someone that really
knows you and understand or
seems to understand you calling you that
it's like [ __ ]
maybe it was right like right i am
stupid
yeah yeah so
i hope i'm sorry i made you guys cry
[ __ ] not this is usually my line but
just kidding i've done a lot of crying
in my myself yeah
so i i hope this helped you guys
out a little bit to kind of understand
yourself a little bit more and what
really
triggers you on the inside um and like
i'm not saying like
maybe you don't have to fix it but now
you understand what really hurts you you
can tell
like see if you're significant i'm like
this really hurts me if you ever felt
that way about me it would really you
know
yeah i totally have had conversations
with casey about the safety thing
yeah like for sure yeah and those of you
at home
i hope this helped you out also it was
very
eye-opening for me um i would love to
hear your
results so your sentence that you made
up at the end of the
exercise and probably shocking how many
people have the same sentence yeah and
then we go through life thinking like
well i'm the only one that actually
feels like but
it's like pretty much everyone's like uh
no one's gonna love me like
i suck you know but everyone feels that
way it's like
we're not alone in that feeling so it's
almost like hey
just realize everyone else feels the
same way and they're only thinking about
themselves too
no one's like oh this [ __ ] ugly
stupid [ __ ] thing
people are just thinking in their head
like man does she think i'm stupid and
ugly yeah
i learned to approach others with
empathy yeah you never know what they're
going through
exactly and i learned actually from what
i've seen in my stream and
every time i've done this exercise a lot
more women
feel more uh or more affected by the you
will never be safe thing
and that's well yeah
yeah so i would love to hear your
results and
how you feel about it if it resonates
with you i hope this helped you guys out
and i hope also this
um helps you guys understand that
getting therapy is not a bad thing yeah
it's good for you actually it's very
brave of you to reach out and try to
especially men especially therapies
therapy yeah name your ego yeah and then
set it aside and then go seek
therapy because it's your ego stopping
you exactly yeah so um
thanks for watching make sure you guys
give us a thumbs up and five stars on
whatever the hell it is that we're on
apple podcast tell them all whatever
they are they're all the same
yeah youtube we love you be safe
be good bye